hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
so person has desire and they also have
these light or a reason working and
there's some sort of interference
between the two of them so how many
different ways can this play itself out
it's worth thinking about this because
then even you can recognize this a
little bit more easily monochrome the
eros table gives you a kind of
typography you might say of different
ways in which we can be in temporal or
lack self-control literally lacking self
mastery
so what are we usually intemperate with
Aristotle says that the main thing cast
with desires for physical pleasure and
that makes good sense I mean think about
times where you set your alarm for 6:00
in the morning and why did you set your
alarm for 6:00 in the morning because
you didn't get on the work that you
needed to get done anymore you wanted to
get up and study had a really good
intention and you said to yourself this
is the right thing for me to do and you
know you went to bed made me run with 11
or 12 all right so you're already
cutting it a little bit close and you'll
have class at say 10 o'clock right so
you're going to get up at 6:00 in the
morning you're gonna really buckle down
and study and you're gonna be so prepped
for class you're getting so much out of
it and then six o'clock comes around and
the alarm goes off and we need it yeah
almost everybody you know I know hits
the snooze button at least once how many
times is okay this in this news bottom
how much work you have yeah you know
Aristotle would probably say why don't
you set the alarm for when you actually
think you'll get it up instead of you
know playing this news button tag game
but you know maybe it's better if you
get up after one snooze than five Jesus
I know some people who can like snooze
but before and out some somebody even
longer than that now what's going on
their reason is telling them something
it's time to get up remember we said we
were going to do this this is a good
thing to do but they don't really feel
like it right what do they feel like
doing it's nice to lay in bed and it
feels good to sleep doesn't it sometimes
you know especially if it's a cold day
what about other things what are other
things we have physical pleasure yeah
yeah food for one thing how many how
many servings should we have you know I
mean if it tastes really good maybe it's
okay to have seconds maybe not thirds
you know maybe it has to do with how
many times we eat there are things like
that and you know again if you're if
you're if you have a lack of
self-control you're not yet vicious
something in you tells you hey this is
enough for you but then your desire says
go when you have another yeah think
about pizza right Pizza comes you've
ordered a pizza and you know a little
order the large because you know if
you're gonna spend the money in it you
get a better cost for the large beats of
the medium pizza so you know you have a
slice well that's good that's probably
enough one big large slice of pizza is
probably all you need and they say I
want to put the rest away
and all have some tomorrow and then you
know our passes really go for another
piece of pizza and you think about it it
probably shouldn't but that desire comes
along it says another piece then maybe
they get half the pizza we don't what
else so food sleep drinking you know not
necessarily alcohol - you could be you
get up a lack of self control with
respect to coffee or tea or soda really
anything that you like drinking what
else what other physical pleasures drugs
yeah it'll take drugs because they make
em kill them yeah sexual activity what
are our strongest desires they can get
you all sorts of trouble I mean think
about that many different ways in which
reason tells us this is not a good idea
and then somebody goes along it does
anyway you know that's what movies are
made up many movies Aristotle doesn't
have the quite as big of a range of
things that he discusses because we've
discovered a lot of new ways to appeal
to our senses people get addicted to
shopping you know I spent I suppose in
some ways if it's just a manner it's not
yet become like here's my mindset and
this is the way it ought to be but if
somebody's forwarding and they think to
themselves this isn't right I probably
shouldn't be doing this but they find
themselves doing it anyway that might be
a type of lack of soft
as well aerosol says there's a few other
things that also fit this angers of
other people think about how difficult
it is once you're actually angry to keep
things in check if you ever have the the
sense as you're arguing with somebody or
you know something's going on that
you're you're actually like starting to
cross a line probably shouldn't say this
but you kind of feel like saying it it's
not really true but it's true enough for
the circumstances that you're gonna call
them that name well that would be anger
leading to a lack of self-control reason
is actually still telling you this is
not a good idea but you end up following
anger and anger actually isn't any kind
of reasoning process eresources
anger is like a hasty servant who here
as part of the instructions and then
goes rushing off to try to do them anger
here is something that tells the person
that hey I'm getting treated badly and
that says I should get revenge and just
rushes off to do there's other good
things other you know putters are good
sometimes it's right to be angry there's
other things that Aristotle says we
kradic or have a lack of self-control
and these are things like well
victory and even talks about children
and parents it's an interesting you
never actually talks about those places
the people sometimes do things are they
tempted to do things to make money that
they know are wrong but they find
themselves overcome by the amount of
money and they still know what's wrong I
feel bad while they're doing it but they
do it this is what Japanese game shows
are made right would you get a complete
stranger with a hammer if I gave you a
million dollars something wouldn't that
I mean if you have no temptation about
that whatsoever and you reject that
immediately they say that would be
completely wrong and I that actually
disgust me
you're probably virtuous if you actually
say to yourself I'm kind of tempted but
that would be the wrong thing to do
get away from me then you have then you
have self control if on the other hand
you say that sounds like a bad thing but
yeah okay I'll do it
then you you laughs off control if you
say sign me up this sounds like a great
idea then you're probably vicious we
said hollow on the range it works so you
can be motivated to do things by desire
for the other people it's its honor or
fame or celebrity you know if you put a
camera and you get people to do crazy
things but they ordinarily would see as
a bad idea
again this is what game shows are made
of and reality show yeah a lot of other
kinds of Tanks of shows as well people
will do a lot of things to appear
certain ways in other people's eyes
victory Aristotle talks about this thing
that it calls filo media Nikkei is the
Greek word for victory another word that
that we could translate by it is
right we're winning a love of winning a
lot of casting other people up a love of
being at the top a love of shutting
other people up and being the one who's
inside
Zetterberg lead us to cross lines you
know where we know that word again we're
doing the wrong thing but we say well in
this case I'm gonna do that it doesn't
always have to be a arguments or
contests I had something like this not
quite so bad anymore
thankfully but with driving any of you
like to pass other people you enjoy it
why do you like to pass Olivia what are
you getting out you're getting there
quicker right that's what you tell
yourself but really why do you like to
be asked other people because you're
putting them behind you you're not
actually getting there any quicker but
you've passed them and it feels like an
achievement this I know if somebody else
passes Union like that
who's that jerk sometimes you'll change
some I don't do this
thank God sometimes to chase them and
then pass them you know well that would
be what Aristotle calls desire for
victory and that can activate us to lack
of self-control what about children and
parents this is a really interesting one
you want to eros all things love your
children you ought to love your parents
you ought to do a lot of things for them
but can you become too preoccupied with
them and end up going over the line so
to speak and doing things that you
shouldn't do out of love or desire to oh
yeah those shows are a good example you
look at those parents and you know you
listen to their justifications and
you're like and I'm not really sure I
think there might be a little bit of
excessiveness to this yeah
toddlers to tiaras all these beauty
shows there's many other things in one
of those ones you can think of the
helicopter parents yeah why what is the
the good that that's interfering well
children like especially when they're
toddlers they need like free
unstructured play in order to develop a
sense of self
yeah the parent becomes too intrusive in
the child the toddler can never develop
that sense of self there comes to
to prepare and if they don't develop
their self they're going to weaken
cystic all in it we fear athletes
associate events or borderline
personalities yeah we've got the
helicopter parent in college when you
see because you've seen something right
there's what's we're like this shows
there's there's sons at college and she
really shows up and knocks on the door
like a piece of beer and like tries to
start partying with his friends okay
that's a different kind of helicopter
current that's not the one who's like
I'm gonna make sure that my child gets
good grades that's yeah it's a kind of
dodging system and what what good does
that interfere with that interferes of
the child's development if it's the
other kind of helicopter parent who you
know calls up the teacher and I
understand why my son or daughter is not
doing so well in your class and first
you have to say I can't tell you
anything because of FERPA
and that you know sometimes they'll like
or I'll beat their child into waving
their FERPA rights and then you know you
start talking with the parent of the
parent or don't like how all sorts of
plans for their kid what the kid is
going to do you know who should actually
be talking with the professor the
student right why it's their
responsibility why else is it what's up
is you use it's part of my autonomy
somebody else says something really yeah
in order to become an independent
autonomous person you actually have to
like stand up for yourself
engage in discussions by yourself learn
how to talk to you know professors store
managers who else would you need
two losses all these people on your own
and if you don't something's you know
going to yeah so the the parent who is
is the helicopter parent who recognizes
that there's something wrong with this
but it actually says I'm still going to
do this they would have a lack of self
control over here on this side that's
the last thing I'm gonna say about this
Aristotle actually distinguishes a few
different ways in which things are going
to be it talks about it perfectly now
the person who has a lack of
self-control does have knowledge of
what's right and wrong
they have general knowledge about it
they may also have you know specific
knowledge about in this circumstance
this is what's what's required are they
using the knowledge that's the pleasure
they're not actually using the knowledge
they're like somebody who is he says
drunk or asleep they actually know
things but they're not using it at that
at that time it's being sort of
disengaged and instead what's happening
if knowledge isn't running show then
desire is something he has to make you
go one way or the other so for Aristotle
it's not your intellect or your
intellect in behind with right desire
then it's going to be your other desires
and they will you know run the show but
then if you keep on doing it eventually
this part will go away it'll become
corrupted and then the risk is granted
lack of self control to advise Aristotle
thinks that most people are kind of in
between lack of self-control and soft
control and it's up to us which way we
go you guys are in a particular point in
your life where we have a lot of control
over this but the tenant you get to my
age you have much less control but you
still have some control